>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Teresa Sierra: Hi everybody.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Terry Sierra.
I'm the Chief of the Serial and
Government Publications Divisions,
which is our sponsoring
division for this program today.
We have with us local
historians, W. Douglas and Fisher
and Joann H. Buckley, who
will be discussing their book
"African American Doctors
of World War I:
The Lives of a 104 Volunteers."
I bought, can you all hear me okay?
Yeah. Okay.
All right.
I thought I would tell you a little
bit about how this came about,
this program came about,
and here's the story.
I hope you find it interesting
because programs at the Library
of Congress start differently,
come from different places.
But in this case, it started
when we received comments
on the National Digital
Newspaper program contact page
from some fellow.
And he said, and I'm going
to read what he said.
"My co-author, Joann H.
Buckley and I spent hours at LOC
and online working with ProQuest
and other digital newspaper archives
to develop these biographies, and
we are most grateful for them.
Without them we would not have
been able to complete our work."
So, that got our attention.
We had to know what was this
book and who wrote this book?
So, at the same time that
this came to our attention,
one of our librarians, Arlene
Balkowski, was, had the assignment
of pulling and getting
things together
for her World War I exhibit.
Which if you haven't seen
it, I recommend it highly.
It's in the Jefferson
Building; it's fantastic.
So, she was in the process
of doing that and it seemed
like a natural thing to
hand her this information.
Well, Arlene ran with it and
within two months she had,
she was in touch with our authors.
She had it all set up.
So basically, it took
us over a year to get
to this point, but here we are.
So, anyway I thought you
might want to know about that.
I also wanted to tell you that one
of the things that has touched me
about knowing about these
folks and their book is
that they were both inspired
by their grandparents.
Both grandfathers served during
the war and Joann's grandmother,
whose picture is over there,
was a nurse in New York tending
to the wounded as they came back.
I was touched by that.
And before I turn over the
program to them, there are a couple
of people that I need to
acknowledge who are with us today,
and we're very thrilled
to have them.
They're over there in that corner.
We have Dr., I don't if you're a
doctor, but Urbane Bass' grandson.
>> Urbane Bass Grandson: Yes.
>> Teresa Sierra: Okay.
And Dr. Richard Sterling
grandson as well.
And we're very pleased that
you could make the trip.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
>> Teresa Sierra: So, one
more thing, and I'll move on.
Joann and Doug brought a number
of artifacts that are part
of their collections
that are on display.
So, after our program, after
their presentation, please,
you can take a couple of
minutes to go and look,
ask questions and so forth.
They will also be around
to sign books.
I see that they are being sold in
the back if you didn't have them.
But you may have it already.
So, without any more
delays here, I give to you,
Douglas Fisher and Joann H. Buckley.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Okay.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Thank you.
Terry hold on a minute.
I'm giving back to Terry.
We're giving back to
the Library of Congress.
We did a tremen-- , we were doing
research and writing for five years.
And we spent a lot of
time in this building.
And we gathered all of our
material and some of the women
in my building sat around my
dining room table for a long time
and we reviewed all this material.
And then another one
had some connections
with a scanning company
and we had it scanned.
And then we had it made searchable
with some wonderful little software.
This is 8000 pages of
material that we gathered he
at the Library of Congress.
And now it's all digitized on
one subject, the World War I,
the African American Doctors,
and we're getting it back
to the Library of Congress.
So here you are Terry.
>> Teresa Sierra: Thank
you very much.
We're delighted to receive it.
>> Joann H. Buckley: We want
some new young writer in on this.
Doug's grandfather,
John North Douglas,
commanded the 317th Motor Supply
Train of the 92nd Division,
an African American combat unit.
He, Doug was fascinated by his
grandfather's letters and diaries,
another book, and began
his research on the war.
Jonathan Rucker was a
black doctor who take
of the 500 troops in
the supply train.
Doug got to know five
of Rucker's 10 children,
even setting up a Rucker family
reunion in Natchez, Mississippi.
In 2009 I entered Doug's life.
I met his family.
Then I met the Rucker family.
I knew something of World War I.
I'd been a history teacher and two
of my grandparents had
been involved in the war.
My grandfather was a sergeant
with the 77th Division,
a teamster with the artillery unit.
My grandmother was a nurse at
Saint Vincent's in New York,
and she took care of
the returning wounded.
She didn't want any of us to
go into nursing after that.
Doug wanted to write
Rucker's biography.
But it was a good story,
but I could not believe
that Rucker was the only doctor.
The Army just doesn't do ones.
So, we went to Fort Des Moines where
Rucker trained to find out more.
No one, including the curator
at Fort Des Moines Museum,
where the physicians received their
basic training knew their names
or even how many of them there were.
We spent months combing
through the files here
at National Archives
before the eureka moment
and the discovery of the list.
It was in an ancient folder of the
U.S. Army Surgeon General's records;
so old that the identification
tab had disintegrated.
It as typed by some clerk 100
years ago on many sheets of paper
with columns of information;
hometowns, medical schools,
graduation years and ages.
The sheets were then glued together
and the resulting document was
four feet long and 18 inches wide.
And then it had been
folded in and in,
until it fit into a standard file.
One hundred years ago, the United
States was largely a country
of racial segregation,
discrimination,
lynching and Jim Crow laws.
These 104 men were among the
nations estimated 1500 African
American doctors.
They had succeeded in gaining
advanced education and training
at a time when it was problematic
for any African American
to achieve such success.
Yet they answered their country's
call and left their practices
to provide medical care
for the fighting men
of the 92nd and the 93rd Divisions.
Sixty percent of these doctors came
from just three African
American medical schools.
The largest contingent
were graduates
of two Tennessee medical schools.
Thirty four from Meharry Medical
School in Nashville and eight
from the University of
West Tennessee in Memphis.
But 16 came from Howard in D.C.
Thirteen from Leonard Medical School
at Shaw University in
Raleigh, two went to Harvard,
three from the University of
Illinois, two from the University
of Michigan, and two from
Northwestern Medical School.
Why would they enlist?
They expected times
would be different.
After the war, they thought they'd
be recognized for their service.
They thought all men of
their race would benefit.
But nothing changed after the war.
But some of, many of these
men would become the leaders
of their communities and
organizations like the NAACP
that would make racial
equality possible.
So we had to tell their stories.
We spent the next five years
at the Library of Congress,
the National Archives,
numerous state
and city historical
associations, libraries,
and with a variety
of newspaper sources.
We met the children
and the grandchildren
of these extraordinary men.
Initially we wrote four historical
journals and spoke to small groups.
Then, after a chance meeting with
Professor Henry Louis Gates, Jr.,
in the elevator of Hay-Adams
Hotel in Washington, well,
actually what happened was we had
gone to a wedding the night before.
And we were coming down
to go to breakfast.
We got out of the elevator and we
saw Henry Louis Gates checking in.
So we stepped over to
the side and we waited
until he got in the elevator.
And then we jumped in with him.
And we started talking as
fast as we possibly could.
And so, he said, "What
is this, a hustle?"
And we said, Doug said,
"Absolutely."
So, we told him about the
project and so he had us, he said,
I don't have a card, but here,
I'll repeat my email address.
I want you to send me one.
And so, we did.
And in the subject line
we put, Hay-Adams Hustle.
It was a Sunday we sent it.
Monday, we heard from him.
He hired us to write 15 of them.
So, he wanted shorter ones.
We're still writing for him.
We're still doing shorter
biographies
for his African American
National biography.
We did this and then
the book came next.
And now Doug will talk about the
Army in 1917, as we entered the war.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: There's your
arrow there for your advancing.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Okay.
This one.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Yes.
>> W. Douglas Fisher:
Thank you for coming.
Now prior to World War I
the U.S. Army was tiny.
I mean, 200,000 people spread around
the world and around this country.
And it was totally segregated.
Black officers were
virtually non-existent.
Nevertheless, between 1917 and 1919,
400,000 African American men served.
Most of them were in
labor and support units.
But 10 thous-- , 10 percent, or
40,000 of these troops served
in the combat units that
we've talked about, the 92nd
and the 93rd divisions in France.
The black officers were
trained at Fort Des Moines Iowa,
with 639 line officers completing
a special officers' training camp,
only done once.
And 104 doctors, who
we're writing about,
completed the medical officers'
training camp that was there.
Things had been written about
the officers' training camp,
but not the medical officers,
and we uncovered that.
Training for the doctors was
rigorous, with a 10-mile march
and a three-day outdoor encampment.
In this picture that you can see
here, this is a picture of the guys
out in their tents at the
encampment on the state fairgrounds
and you can see the
rollercoaster in the background.
I don't think they were
having a lot of fun, though.
These doctors were also given
command of the medical detachments
with 10 enlisted men in each of the
detachments, saving some leadership.
After the MOTC training, the
doctors were assigned to the 92nd
or 93rd Divisions and spread
across eight different U.S.
encampments across the country.
Then in 1918, the combat
units were sent to France.
The 93rd Division, which
consisted of 12,000 soldiers
and four national guard
regiments arrived overseas first.
The French wanted American troops
to fill its decimated ranks.
So General Pershing gave him the
93rd Division, the four regiments
of that, and the French loved it.
They were terrific.
They fought more time, one of
the units there fought longer
than any other American
unit in combat.
The 92nd Buffalo Division,
consisting of 27,000 men,
arrived in mid-1918 and fought with
the American 1st and 2nd armies.
That's the unit that my
grandfather served in.
The 104 doctors were assigned to
frontline medical detachments,
ambulance companies, and field
hospitals, right up front.
They endured combat and suffered
aerial and artillery attacks.
Many were wounded from the
effects of exploding gas shells.
Gas was a terrible
problem in World War I.
One doctor was killed in field.
His grandsons are with
us here today.
Interesting, almost as many American
soldiers died of disease as died
in combat in World War I.
Army doctors such as
ours faced both the enemy
and killer diseases including the
horrendous Spanish flu epidemic
of 1918 that killed tens of
millions of people worldwide.
Today we're going to
share a glimpse of three
of these extraordinary doctors
with you and Joann's going
to lead off introducing you
to Dr. Thomas E. Jones,
who is from this area.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Dr. Thomas E.
Jones served with great distinction
for more than five years
in the National Guard
and the Army earning a
Distinguished Service Cross,
the highest Army declaration
for heroism.
>> W. Douglas Fisher:
Second highest.
>> Joann H. Buckley:
The second highest.
A military expert.
No, he is really.
He also earned the
French Croix de Guerre
for his courage under
fire in France.
Born in Lynchburg, Virginia,
where his father was a merchant,
Jones attended public
schools and graduated
from Lynchburg High School in 1896.
He went on to Howard University in
Washington, D.C. During college,
Jones worked at different
time as a newsboy, waiter,
messenger, laborer, and watchman.
It was hard work, but
he was cheerful
and determined, and he succeeded.
He entered Howard University's
Medical School in 1908 and graduated
with his MD degree in 1912.
He interned at D.C.'s Freedman
Hospital for a year, and then,
was then appointed
anesthetist at the hospital;
a position he actually held after
the war and through until 1917.
Nineteen 14 he served in the D.C.
National Guard as a Lieutenant
in Company C of the
1st Separate Battalion;
an African American component
of the National Guard.
Nineteen 17, when America
entered the first World War,
Jones volunteered for the
Army Medical Reserve Corp
and entered the Medical Officers'
Training Camp at Fort Des Moines.
After 60 days of training
he was sent to Camp Meade
to join the 368th Infantry
Regiment of the 92nd Division.
And he served with them
throughout the war.
Lieutenant Jones received his
Distinguished Service Cross
and French Croix de Guerre in
the Argonne Forest in France.
He was also promoted to Captain
for displaying extraordinary
heroism while attending the wounded
in an open area under
machine gun fire.
The Army citation says quote,
"While dressing a wounded runner,
a machine gun bullet passed
between his arms and his chest.
And the man was killed
within a few yards of him."
Another account of the incident
says that "Under falling shell
and machine gun fire the boys say
he walked out and got wounded men
with same coolness that was his
when he was putting a patient
to sleep for an operation."
Following the war, Dr. Jones
returned to Freedman's Hospital
in Washington, D.C. as
resident assistant surgeon.
In 1936, he was promoted to the
top job, becoming Surgeon in Chief,
until he retired in 1942,
after 27 years of service.
He also taught at Howard
University's Medical School.
The Smithsonian has a
photograph of Dr. Jones
with Eleanor Roosevelt
in its collection.
He was clearly recognized
as a leader
in the African American community.
His commitment to his
community is remarkable.
He was an active member
of at least 10 national
and local benevolent associations.
Militarily he belonged to the League
of Valor whose members are medal
of honor winners and recipients
of the Army Distinguished
Service Cross.
In 1934, his American Legion Post
adopted a resolution deploring
segregation and civil service
and urging the passing
of anti-lynch bill.
In 1941, as Surgeon and
Chief of Freedman's Hospital,
he represented the medical world in
the second selective service drawing
in Washington, D.C.
for World War II.
By 1950, at the age of
70, he was semi-retired,
still maintained an office
downstairs in his four-story house
that we found in Washington,
D.C. It's a handsome townhouse.
He died of a coronary thrombosis
1958, just before his 78th birthday.
He was buried with full
medical, military honors
in Arlington National Cemetery,
next to his first wife.
Dr. Jones believed
that the best interest
of his race would be promoted by
acting for the good of the masses,
rather than by the
accumulation of property
and by investing financially
in local community projects.
He as an extraordinary, patriotic,
courageous, well-respected,
and hardworking physician
and community leader.
And now Doug with talk about
another of our doctors.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Thanks Joann.
Our next distinguished MOTC
graduate is a Dr. William Holmes,
also known as Billy Dyer.
He's featured in a book by Clif
Cleaveland entitled "Healers
and Heroes", published back in
2004 by the American College
of Physicians in Philadelphia.
You can see the picture there.
The arrow's pointing to him.
It's one of the six that
they featured there.
He was also the subject of a 1992
book by an author, William Maxwell,
entitled "Billy Dyer
and Other Stories."
Billy was a personal
friend of William Maxwell's.
Uh, Dr. Dyer also served in
the Buffalo Division along
with my grandfather,
Captain Douglas.
Dyer's written accounts and
descriptions which we found
in Schomburg, up in New York in the
library up there, his descriptions
of France helped us paint
really vivid mental images
of what they experienced.
His hometown of Lincoln,
Illinois halfway
between St. Louis and Chicago.
After graduation from Lincoln
College and the University
of Illinois Medical School in
1916, he interned in Kansas City.
Internships were very
dear, very hard to find
for black physicians in those years.
After Dyer volunteered for
Army service he received orders
to proceed to Fort Des Moines.
When he left Lincoln,
300 people saw him off
at the train station; amazing.
His diary recorded his
disappointment with his quarters
when he reached the fort at Fort
Des Moines, which he described
as a cold room in a stable.
A lot of people weren't
very happy with that.
[ Audio cuts off ]
And harrowing war-time
experience clearly shows
that in combat he gained
an appreciation
for the value of the drills.
After completely his
training, he was assigned to,
as the Medical Officer to the 92nd
Division's 317th Ammunition Train.
He was assigned to Camp Funston,
Kansas out in the Midwest.
In route from Hoboken, New Jersey,
New York basically to Brest France,
Lieutenant Dyer's assignment
at sea was
to give physical examinations
to 600 men.
He said the only excitement during
the voyage was on June 21, 1918,
when shots were fired from all the
surrounding ships at what proved
to be a floating beer keg.
Dyer wrote that once in France,
the 317th was marked to a barracks
that had been a prison camp
during the time of Napoleon.
He said it was a terrible
and dirty old place.
In a letter home, my grandfather
described these same barracks
as being badly crowded with
no beds or cots and wrote
that they were supplied with
French beds, which consisted
of three one inch by 12 inch planks,
pine planks, fastened together
with two cleats at the
bottom to keep them
from lying flat on the floor.
There was no straw and they
were very uncomfortable.
It was called a rest camp, where
troops regained their land legs
and rest after the
three-week ocean voyage.
My grandfather wrote that the term
rest was a gross misnomer, saying,
"I defy anyone to rest there."
The officers were assigned
to small room downstairs.
It was damp, musty, and smelled
of urine and fecal matter.
There was a stone floor and
there were no lights available,
but they had a few candles.
It was summer and the weather
was drizzly and disagreeable.
The flies were thick and ravenous
and the windows were not screened.
My grandfather's letter
reported, "The men were touchy
for want of sleep and food.
They were not fed from early
morning until late in the afternoon.
He said, finally, got
a few bedding rolls.
Mine is missing.
Got four used blankets
from a guardhouse.
They smelled awful.
The atmosphere seems thoroughly
saturated with a fecal odor.
Fortunately, after several days
they boarded trains going eastward
to the division's training
area Bourbonne-les-Baines.
Then at the end of August, they
were on the move again to the front.
Dyer recalled the convoy
drove without lights
and they kept passing broken down
Army vehicles and infantry men,
who because of fatigue, had
fallen out of line to rest.
They always traveled at night.
The convoy destination
was Raon-l'Etape
in the eastern Vosges
mountains, which was described
as a desperate place full of
graves, where Dyer said he gave
up counting the houses
with the roofs gone.
After nearly a month
in the mountains,
they moved up to the Argonne Forest.
Dyer wrote quote, "No
accommodations here.
Not even water to drink
or cook with.
Mud everywhere over shoe tops.
While camped in this wet filthy
woods, many of our boys became ill
from the dampness,
cold, and exposure,
thereby causing me much work
and worry caring for them.
On September 25, at the outset of
the great Meuse-Argonne Campaign,
the 47-day campaign where more
lives were lost than ever before
in any battle of American troops.
Dyer said quote, "The old woods
trembled as if by earthquake.
The flashes of the cannon
lighted up the inside of our tents
and our ears were deafened.
At the hospital, Dyer
saw a steady stream
of ambulances bring
wounded soldiers.
The dead were also being
brought back on trucks piled
like cord wood and dripping blood."
In early October, the 92nd
Division was transferred
to the AEF's second Army
and Dyer was sent southeast,
through a wasteland, which he
described, which he said, in which,
even the grass was burned.
And they were sent to the village
of Belleville on the Moselle River.
He set up an infirmary in a
small electrical plant there.
Because of the constant
cold and rainy weather,
there was a great deal of sickness
among the African American troops.
The division's artillery had
been in training in the south
of France, separated, since July.
And Dyer wrote that, "Major
Howard, my commanding officer
from whom I'd been separated about
four months, called to see me
and complimented me
on my good work."
He was very pleased with that.
All through October and early
November the 317th Ammunition Train
labored on.
Everyone was hearing
much talk of peace
and preparing for the final drawing.
The 92nd was part of a large
attack on the city of Metz,
the German stronghold
throughout the war.
The attack began in
earnest on November 9, 1918.
And in it the division
suffered many casualties.
The fighting, the war,
essentially ended two days later
with the November 11
armistice on the 11th hour
of the 11th day of the 11th month.
Lieutenant Dyer wrote a month
later, in December 1918,
he was awakened by an orderly.
In a heavy fog, a passenger train
had plowed into a troop train full
of happy French soldiers
returning home from the front.
The bodies of the dead and dying
were pinned under the wreckage.
"He spent the night", he said,
"Dressing wounds and putting splints
on broken arms and broken legs."
Just three days later, on
December 18th, the 317th began
to leave Belleville on foot.
Six days later, after traveling
on foot, by truck, and train,
they finally reached the village of
[Inaudible] in Normandy in the rain
and the snow on Christmas
Eve, where even the people
of [Inaudible] took them in.
Finally, two months later on the
morning of February 22, 1919,
the 317th marched to Brest
Harbor where they were ferried
out to the ship Aquitania,
for the trip home.
Dyer said his cabin had quote,
"Mahogany fittings and private bath,
taps for fresh and
salt water and soap.
A far cry from anything
he'd experienced
or encountered during
his time in France.
Then after the war, he established
his medical practice in Kansas city.
In addition to his private medical
practice, he served as a surgeon
for the Santa Fe railroad, an
enormous enterprise at the time.
He was invited to join
the American Association
of Railway Surgeons in 1946.
And in 1947 he was the lone legal
member present among 400 surgeons
who attended the 58th
annual convention
at the Palmer House in Chicago.
He was quoted as saying, "I was
quite interested in the types
of operations for mangled
hands and feet.
For quite frequently, we railroad
physicians have to care for victims
of railroad [inaudible] and wrecks."
He was also the surgeon
for the Kansas City,
Kansas Police Department.
A 1947 news article said he served
as the lone police surgeon
there for many years.
He was honored in 1953 by
his home city of Lincoln,
Illinois at its Centennial
celebration as one
of its 10 most distinguished
men and the only negro.
In January 1956, at 70 years
old, he wrote from Kansas City
to an old friend in California
saying, "In the last four months,
I've been put on the staffs of three
of the major hospitals in our city.
I thought at first it was an honor,
but with the increase in activities
that such appointments entailed,
my work has increased twofold."
Since it was the first time that one
of my race had such appointments,
I'd been working diligently
to make good,
thereby keeping those doors open.
At age 70, he was still a
surgeon for the Santa Fe Railroad
and the Kansas City
Police Department.
He died in 1958, at
age 71, and was buried
in a mixed-race cemetery
in Lincoln, Illinois.
And now Joann will talk
to you about Dr. Bass.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Dr.
Urbane Bass was the only one
of the 104 African
American doctors of the 92nd
and 93rd Divisions killed
in action in France.
About five years ago Doug and
I climbed into the choir loft
at the Fredericksburg Shiloh
Baptist Church to get pictures
of this extraordinary stained
glass window that was installed
by the congregation in his memory.
Bass was born in Richmond, Virginia
to Rosa and Richard J. Bass.
His father was a salesman,
shoes and clothing
in the 1880's, insurance
in the 1900's.
His mother stayed home
with the six children.
The family live in Richmond
on East Duval Street.
Urbane worked as a
clerk while in school.
He graduated from Virginia Union
University in Richmond in 1902
and then went on to
Leonard Medical School
of Shaw University
in Raleigh in 1906.
After graduating from
Leonard, he married Maude Vass,
the sister of his medical
school classmate, Rufus Vass.
And then he opened a
medical practice and pharmacy
on Williams Street,
in Richmond, Virginia.
By 1909 he'd moved his practice
and his pharmacy north
to Fredericksburg.
He was the city's first
African American physician
since reconstruction.
The practice located on Amelia
Street was well received
by the African American community,
in spite of the local hospital's
denial of privileges to Bass.
By 1916 his practice and
his family were growing.
In 1917, this father of four
wrote to Secretary of War,
Newton Baker, offering his services.
One of Bass' friends, J.B.
Morris told his family,
Dr. Bass was dedicated
to serving his country
in a time of critical need.
He knew or men were going
to die in France and told me
that he would give his life
to save them, if he had to.
I could see the sincerity
in his eyes, Baker said,
I mean, excuse me, Morris said.
"He was committed to the end."
Bass received his commission
as First Lieutenant
in the Medical Reserve Corp and
was 37 years old when he reported
to duty at Fort Des
Moines on August 14, 1917.
After basic medical officer
training at Fort Des Moines he
and Rufus Vass were sent
to Camp Funston, Kansas.
Bass went to France with
the 372nd infantry regiment
of the 93rd Division, which
was immediately turned
over to the French and
sent to the front lines.
On October 17, 1918, he
was frantically working
on wounded soldiers at a forward
aid station under heavy German fire.
He was hit with shrapnel when
a shell exploded near him.
Both of his legs were severed.
While he was dying, he actually
continued to direct medics
on how to treat his wounds.
He died before he could
be taken from the field.
Bass was awarded the Distinguished
Service Cross posthumously.
And that citation reads,
"For extraordinary heroism
in action near Mont Blanc, France
on October 1 through 5, 1918."
"Lieutenant Bass", it said,
"Administered first aid in the open
and under prolonged
and intense shell fire,
until he was severely wounded and
carried from the field", unquote.
It was the policy then
that if someone died
in the field they were buried,
until they could be returned
to the United States.
So, he died in 1918.
He was not returned for
reburial until July of 1921.
He became the first African American
commissioned officer to be buried
in Fredericksburg National Cemetery.
He lies in Officers' Row near
the entrance to the cemetery.
The Social Services building
in Fredericksburg is named
the Bass-Ellison building
in honoring him and
Richard C. Ellison,
another African American doctor
who served the community.
And back to the Shiloh Baptist
Church, you really have to go
to Fredericksburg and
see this to believe it.
But you can see the, from
the inscription there
that the community was very much
in his debt and very distraught
about losing him at
the, during the war.
Dr. Bass had a love worthy of
envy when he married Maude Vass.
The couple had four children,
three daughters, Ann, Frances-May,
and Ruth and one sign,
son, Urbane F. Bass.
After his death, Maude
was a widow at age 32.
She had quite a difficult
time accepting his death.
In 1922 she was staying
with a family Washington,
D.C. when she was taken
to a Washington asylum
because of her violent,
nervous state.
A few weeks earlier she
had attempted suicide
by jumping from a two-story window.
It was her father, the
Reverend Samuel N. Vass,
who had her committed for
care for several months.
Early in 1923 she and four
children moved back to her hometown
of Raleigh, North Carolina.
There she raised her family
and taught music to the blind
for 30 years at North Carolina
State School for the Blind.
Maude and her Vass family saw
that all four children were
well-educated for productive lives.
Daughter Frances Mae Bass
graduated from Shaw University.
She completed some graduate work at
Columbia University and then worked
for the Durham City School
System for nearly 30 years.
She married Charles Clinton
Spalding of Durham, General Counsel
of the North Carolina Mutual
Life Insurance Company.
Ruth graduated from Shaw University
and obtained a master's degree
from the University of Michigan.
She taught at Mary Ellen
Teacher's College in Crockett,
Texas before marrying
Moses Newsome [ph].
The couple then moved to Charleston,
West Virginia where the
reverend was the pastor
of the First Baptist Church.
Ann married Richard Sterling
and moved to Washington,
D.C. Urbane Bass, Jr. followed
in his father's footsteps
and became a physician.
And we are honored that we have two
of the Bass grandchildren
with us today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> W. Douglas Fisher:
Now in closing,
let me say we've enjoyed sharing
with you a glimpse of the lives
of these three really
extraordinary doctors.
Now doctors Jones, Dyer,
and Bass were only three
of the 104 African American doctors
who answered their country's call.
Excuse me.
But all of the 104 doctors endured
as black in a Jim Crow world
and what they accomplished
despite society's racial divide is
truly remarkable.
If you live to see the
Civil Rights legislation
of the mid 1960's enacted,
but their efforts
and accomplishments definitely
helped pave the way for it.
The 18 months that these
doctors spent serving in the Army
between 1917 and 1919, provided
them with new medical skills
and life experiences well
beyond what they'd learned
in their medical school lessons.
Their new organization
and leadership skills were
unique for most physicians.
Most were able to use these skills
and continue to serve our nation
in their African American
communities for decades.
The story of these patriotic men
in World War I was lost
history for 100 years.
We're just delighted and pleased we
rediscovered it so it can be shared
with you and future
scholars a century later.
Thank you very much for
you time and attention.
We'd be glad to answer questions
and we have some things
there you can look at.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Questions.
>> Yeah, I just want to
thank you both so much.
And yeah, if you want to ask
questions, the one thing we ask is
that you have to repeat
the questions right?
You have to repeat the question
so it will be on the webcast.
And thank you so much Joann
and Doug for your presentation.
It was so eye-opening and I
just think it was terrific
and I hope people have
more questions.
Thank you.
>> By the time of World War II
the Army was still segregated.
Did they have separate
training camps
for the doctors during World War II?
Had they learned from the
World War I experience?
>> W. Douglas Fisher: They did
not have a special training camp.
This was the only one
in history was this one
at Fort Des Moines in
the First World War.
There were reserve units
that had been developed.
And so you still had National
Guard units and reserve units.
You had people slightly better
prepared for the Second World War
than we were for the First,
but not terribly well.
Yeah.
>> I was just wondering
as I was listening to you,
and looking at all those pictures,
how did they get medications
out to the field?
Did they have a way to, did
they carry it with them?
>> W. Douglas Fisher: The question
was how did they get medications
and things to the field?
And actually, they med-,
they had a medical unit.
The called it a Sanitary Train.
There was 317th Sanitary Train
and that was all of the medics,
the doctors, and it included
people that were doing logistics.
And so my grandfather's
supply train, for example,
would be carrying medicines
and things to the front.
The difficulty was that the Germans
by this time had decent aviation
and they also had artillery in
place and it was a static front.
So people, it was very hard to move
things around during the daytime.
So it all had to be done in the
dark at night with blackouts.
I mean, it's hard to imagine, I
mean, thank goodness the moon came
out a few times to help
them get these things done.
But they would move things
up to a forward aid station
and take the bandages,
the basic bandages, so on.
And then they would come
back to an ambulance company
where there would be more logistics.
And then they would come back
to a field hospital where,
where they would be, and
then they would be triaged
and to base hospitals which
were even further back
if they were not able
to recover there.
But it's the logistics
and the organization
that it takes to run an Army.
I mean the division had 28,000 men.
That's a lot of people.
It took days to move them.
It took lots of trucks,
lots of trains,
and lots of people walking long
distances just to move them
from one location to the next.
If you look at the, there's one map
over here that shows the disposition
of these forces at the end
of the war in December.
And you can im-- , I
mean, it's just miles.
It's miles in this direction,
miles in that direction
to get 28,000 people
disbursed and organizationally.
They learned a lot about
organization and how
to organize hospitals
in the process.
Yes.
>> Were the base hospitals
also segregated?
>> W. Douglas Fisher:
I don't believe so.
I think, no, I can't
imagine that they were.
Actually, the hospitals were
segregated within the hospital.
But the hos-- , they didn't
have a black-based hospital.
So, they had segregation
within it, but they didn't have
that many people that were moved
back to the base hospitals.
If you didn't die in the front,
then you would be disfigured perhaps
from the shrapnel and the gas.
But the numbers were much
more, were different.
There were 200,000 African Americans
in the combat zone over there,
but only 40,000 of them
were in actual combat.
That's dwarfed by the size of
the American, the white officers
and the white soldiers
that were there.
So, there were many more of
them that had to be cared for.
Yes. Yes.
>> And how many families did you get
a chance to interview [inaudible]?
>> W. Douglas Fisher:
A dozen, 15, 20.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Maybe 20.
>> W. Douglas Fisher:
Maybe 20, uh-huh.
Well we met two people today
that we'd never talked to before.
Urbane Bass and Mr. Sterling, the
grandsons of Dr. Urbane Bass here.
And so, we continue
to have people reach
out as they learn the
story and so on.
We had one very interesting
experience in Los Angeles.
One of the physicians is
named Claudius Ballard
and he fought with the French.
Quite an interesting guy.
It's a good story in here too.
But his son is now in his 90's.
We spent some time with his son.
He's a retired fire
chief in Los Angeles.
And we met, we spent time with
his grandson who's a minister
out in Los Angeles.
We did this just a couple months ago
when we were coming back
from a trip out west.
The family people have learned
so much from us and we've learned
so much from the families.
It's been a wonderful
exchanging of information.
And it's, a lot of these children,
grandchildren were
born after the war.
So, what did their dads or
grandads tell them about the war?
Usually not much.
So, we've been able to give
them a lot of information
that they had no idea about
and then they've been able
to give us a lot as well.
>> Joann H. Buckley: When we were
at Ballard, the son, his unit,
when we were at his home, we were
telling him, because he had been,
he and his father never
could talk, never, you know,
it was like he came back and he,
this was his reaction to battle.
And so, the son, so anyway he
went off and he left the family.
And so, the son was
so angry about that,
that the father had
received the Croix de Guerre,
and when we were sitting in his
living room and we were telling him
about what his father went through
at the 93rd and what a horrendous,
you know, time he had and
everything, finally then,
he says to his son, "Upstairs
under the bed, there's a picture.
Why don't you go and get it?"
And it was his father's Croix de
Guerre, the beautiful picture of it.
So, he brought it down to share it
with his son for the first time.
So, this is, you know,
not unusual though.
You know, there's so much
death and destruction there
that they would come
back with battle fatigue
or whatever they call it now.
You know, so we saw that.
We were there when this kind of
realization came to the family.
That was very rewarding.
Yeah.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: It's
actually changed the way he feels
about his father.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Yeah.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Yeah.
He was very moved by that.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Yes, Richard.
>> I, I have one question and
something not very important, but,
was my grandfather on the
front line when he was killed?
He treated soldiers
on the front line.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Absolutely.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Yes.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Yes.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: The
question was, was his father
in the front line when
he was killed?
>> Joann H. Buckley: Grandfather.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Grandfather on
the front lines when he was killed?
And the answer is yes,
most definitely.
>> Thank you.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Uh-huh.
He was at a forward aid station.
Forward aid stations are right
up there with the regiments.
And he was with the regiment.
They were right there, indeed.
>> You said he received
Distinguished Service Cross,
I believe.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Yes.
>> Do you know when
he received that?
>> W. Douglas Fisher:
I don't know offhand.
It was, he received it
posthumously, obviously.
But I don't know the
actual date it was received.
But it was in that timeframe.
It was not 50 years later
or something of that sort.
>> Joann H. Buckley: You can
probably find out from the Army.
In fact, you could probably
get a copy of it or get a copy
of the medal and the citation
from, by contacting the Army.
Even the Army Museum do
you think in Arlington.
>> W. Douglas Fisher:
We probably can find it
for you in our research papers.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Yeah.
Because we, we have done
that trying to, yes.
We'll look.
>> Thank you so much.
>> W. Douglas Fisher:
Sure, by all means.
>> I have three very
short questions.
Are Dr. Dyer's accounts
at the Schomburg
in the form of diaries or letters?
>> W. Douglas Fisher: What he
wrote was letters that were ty--
, later typed, transcribed.
And so, there's about a 24-page
double spaced document that he wrote
about his experiences
at the Schomburg.
And we have a copy,
we got a copy of that.
And it was fascinating reading
because I could blend it
with my grandfather's comments about
the same place at the same time.
The Ammunition Train was here.
The Supply Train was here.
They were all moving together.
It was very vivid.
>> These are quick questions.
Can you repeat what you said
at the beginning of the program
about the beautiful music that
was playing to give credit for it?
And can you say a word about your
collection that's on display?
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Certainly.
Could we comment about the music
that we were playing before.
There's an album, it's a DVD now
and it's obviously available online
about the James Reese Europe
band, which was the band
for the 369th Infantry Regiment.
James Reese Europe was a famous
musician and he'd been recruited to,
by the commanding officer
of the Harlem Hillfighters they
called them to serve as a band.
Every unit had a band for
marching and for parades and so on.
He recruited some other
great musicians in New York.
When the band got to France it
brought jazz to France, to Europe.
And the French absolutely loved
it and you can imagine those tunes
in the time of war how
they were embraced.
I mean it was spirited music
and then it gave you a
good sense of spirit--
>> Yes.
>> Uplifting.
>> Clubs in Paris, you know,
because jazz is a very
important part of Paris.
If you go to Paris, do
go to the jazz clubs,
because this is where it came from.
>> Well, I downloaded the, I
had heard a lot of the music,
but I downloaded it
onto my cell phone.
So, I plugged the cell phone in here
and that's what you
were hearing earlier.
>> And then she had-
>> W. Douglas Fisher: You had
a last question, oh what the,
about the collection over here.
The collection, a friend of mine
served on a board with me at a bank.
And one of his uncles
had this collection
and it actually is
much bigger than this.
And he didn't know
what to do with it.
He was ill.
So, he asked me if I could take
it over and share it with someone.
So, we went to the National World
War I museum out in Kansas City,
Missouri, showed them
all the stuff we had.
I mean, 50, 60 pieces of
things and they loved it.
And they asked for about half of it.
We donated about a half of it.
It's there at the museum
in Kansas City.
And then we kept pieces of it.
Some of it is still in our house,
but they wouldn't let
us bring the bayonets
into the Library of Congress.
They were afraid we--
>> Joann H. Buckley:
I don't know why.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Afraid
we might get killed, I guess.
So, there is some, that's the
story there on the collection here.
Yes.
>> I was just curious, you
have these visitors, guests,
how did they find out
about the program
and did they tell you what they
knew about their grandfather?
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Well, we have
had some conversations with that.
Joann reached out to Dr. Bass.
>> Joann H. Buckley: I
found him on the internet.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Joann H. Buckley: There was
an article about his fishing
and it said that he was living
in Washington, D.C. And so,
I looked him up and called him.
And so, we have been communicating
back and forth since then.
But he already purchased
seven of our books
for his family and everything.
I wasn't aware he was here
and I guess you guys weren't
aware that we were here.
So, we've all been in this area.
>> W. Douglas Fisher:
So he's another hero
for buying so many books.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Okay.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Yes, ma'am.
>> [Inaudible audience question].
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Well, Joann
can tell you all about that,
because she's the lady that
really put it all together.
But we have a batch
for each physician.
We had files for each doctor.
So there, those were all scanned and
there are all sorts of those PDFs.
So, there are 104 of
those plus there's a lot
of background information that we
have, general information in there.
It's really, it's all our research.
And we, some of it as duplicated
because you could get it
from so many different directions.
So, we tried to eliminate
a lot of the duplication.
But I think it's all there.
Is there anything more you can add?
>> Joann H. Buckley: No.
We didn't do many of the photographs
because that wasn't working well.
So, we will, they will
find their way, somewhere.
Maybe the Army museum.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Yeah.
The National Army Museum that
they're building down here
in Fort Belvoir, it's going to
be a 250-million-dollar museum.
The Army's never had a museum.
I mean Marines got one
down the road on 95.
The Army needs one too.
>> Uh-huh.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: The
Air Force has one I guess
out at Wright Patt
out in Dayton, Ohio.
So, the Army's a little bit behind.
They have smaller ones at different
places, at Fort Benning and,
you know, at different bases, posts.
But there's never been a
national museum for the Army.
So, they're hard at
work at building there
and we've been supporting
that activity.
And we will probably
donate whatever they would
like to have to that one as well.
>> I just want to thank you
both for your diligence in terms
of your research, intending to look
for the names and discovering them
as you did in [inaudible]
in the archives.
Because if it wasn't for you,
this information would not be able
to summated in the way that it has.
And I really appreciate
you all's efforts
and what you all have done with it.
And I hope you all
continue to do your research
for others in that particular book.
>> Joann H. Buckley: Thank you.
>> W. Douglas Fisher: Thank you.
We really appreciate that.
[Applause].
>> Thank you all for coming.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.